Yes.
So in 1974 i was living in your
ella in the us new england plateau.
And lots of people travelling from.
From nimbin to sydney
would go by the back road
and stay at our place overnight so i
was to get lots of news about what was
happening in them and the setting up
a ton of bull and it was part of me
that wanted to go back and
feel the promise that we made
that the public meeting
we said that said that.
That name and the queerest vessel would
bring young people back to the town
and repopulate the area and revitalize it.
And it's turned into a slogan
by the architecture students
that we would recycle member and
we would recycle a town. And.
I could see it was happening and slowly.
So i wanted to go along and five it up so.
We got an invitation from a group called
the educational smorgasbord which was
going to base the balance
and there's a gordon lang
that retired primary school teacher got
some money from the schools commission at
that stage to develop community
learning and we had some expertise at
that from the the festival
the learning exchange
that happened at the festival
we had a model for doing that.
So rather than take its job as an individual
i formed a partnership with a couple
of people including in chance.
Who was the site manager at the festival
the guy most responsible for the physical.
Works on the festival. We formed a company
called the reality construction company.
And our job was to go and. You
know. Turn myths into reality.
We're going to create this new
community new futures in nimbin
and we're all about flash and
flair and doing it with style
and sort of a feeling
that nimbin would come a
bit too gumboot you know
sort of lost in the mud
because i mean limits say
that the people who found it tangible
and did so under the most
horrendous conditions
that 50 people living in a single house you
know in the heaviest rains for you know
sort of 20 years.
It was desperate times
and no money no money to do any
development work to buy the tools
and materials you know like and lots of
madness and lots of mad people coming in.
Plugging in and wanting help
and it was kind of stuff.
Also cites you know this strange mixture
of pioneers and parasites and sites
and paranoid. You know like weird
stuff. The vision it collected.
So we came back to nimbin
and first we sort of caressed
into nimbin lethargy people.
And the company was working
kind of blew apart.
The reality construction company
never actually got the name
and blew apart in lennox ed gordon
lang wouldn't let us set up in them
and because he didn't want to be
polluted by the aquarius dream.
We want to get occasional smorgasbord
to be seen as kind of straight.
It was kind of ironic the only people
interested in these new ideas were the
hippies of course but so it was.
We did a couple of good things including
tour the yellow brick road shows.
Nigel triffitt sort of
fear an education piece.
Anyway would blow apart and
i ended up living in them
and again working with my partner.
On community development and what what
became obvious to us immediately was that.
What we'd taken for granted.
While organizing the quest queries
festival had been forgotten.
People for example didn't know
that you could hire the hall to have a
public meeting you know there's so much
antagonism a grown up between the people
who stayed after the festival on the
townspeople at the festival
the community services
that were seen things being withheld
and not available to people so.
We realised that building this community
was going to be grassroots work and.
And the beginning of it was like just
learning how to have meetings again learning
how to have community meetings.
One of the legacies of the
queerest festival was
that the festival had acquired
property in the main street of nimbin.
I mention the rs sell whole have
been purchased by the festival and
that was sold after the festival
to a group of people who said
that they were going to stay behind
and you know some of them were
already owning property and
that the building would be there for
community function and we ensured
that there was a sufficient spread of
owners that can never be sold. Right.
No one everyone had to agree to sell it
and there's no way these people would
ever agree the rainbow cafe the lease
and the rainbow cafe was extended and taken
up by the tangible force cooperative
and.
My partner had purchased the tomato sauce
battery which was an old general store in
the main street
and these people these buildings were
all of a level for community business
particularly for the new settlers.
This contrast of what was
happening over at main arm
and mullumbimby where the people had
settled in the hills in the main valley
and around there and had no presence
to speak of in the town name
and always always had a shopfront
present for the new settlers now
and this was an advantage for the early
community development organisation because
we had a central place to
organise services from the.
The the media factory which is what we
call the aerosol hole became a healing
center and swear. Carol.
Norman stannard in the first acupuncture
practice on the north coast massages was
offered there and herbal treatments
and also it became the centre for
organising the birth and beyond group.
The home birthing unit that came later.
Well we sat in the back of the media factory
in had the first meetings of what was
to become the home builders
association because they came aware
that the zoning the lands owning was not
what people wanted people want to divide
land and allow other people
to build houses on it.
So there was lots of land
available very cheaply
but the zoning required you can only
build one house behind hectares.
Now people are already building their
houses by 74 on these properties
and are illegal.
So the home builders association was
formed to negotiate with the council about
changing the zoning and.
The first meeting so this home builders
association were about learning how to have
meetings and this was critical
because what had happened was
that everyone had a piece of the dream
that had been seeded by the aquarius
festival but no forum for it.
So when the forum was created.
Everyone came more or less
vomited their frustration
and their dream onto the meeting there was
lots of talk but no listening. Right.
So we had to work very hard at
establishing ways of having meetings
and basically the format
of sitting in a circle.
I have introductions everyone spoke went
round the circle everyone spoke introduced
themselves and said what
they were at the meeting for
and then we would set the
agenda from what had come up
and then we would talk
right. And just require.
Some moderation as a whole argument
that structure was a possible.
The chairman i can stuff quickly.
You know sharing it round
but basically there was someone who
said you're speaking too much.
We got you and said i think someone
took responsibility for the meeting.
Now having established the rules
and having established the process of
listening to people we moved very quickly.
And the home builders association was an
enormously successful negotiating body.
We got membership.
All over the place i mean
but one of the stories about the home
builders association like all good voluntary
associations we needed some money to spend
so we said we'd have to have a benefit
concert. We had the benefit concert
we realised there are no musicians.
You know chris introduced not to
musicians together into the area
but they weren't playing together.
So we only had a couple of people
singing songs will get us you know
but it's still a good thing but out of
that result we've got to do something about
the music and this is also a priority.
So i was we were approached by a group
who want to set up a folk club in
tomato sauce and we said wacko this
is just what we've been waiting for.
So we you know my partner and i threw
our support behind the folklore
and the folk club. Took off like
a rocket always people came out
and started playing the music together.
And listening to each other and forming
new combinations and we hurting
and practicing and bringing new
songs to the to the. Folk club.
Suddenly there was a flowering
of music in them and.
So
when we came to do the next benefit homebuilt
association which was only like three
months down the track.
We had five different combinations of
musicians fighting for the states you know
this is all voluntary we have
people saying ok we want to fly.
We've rehearsed this for the
home builders association.
So that was the kind of organisation
was going on at the time and the name
and news were started up the
name news was sort of a romeo.
To cap staple publication. When
we introduced rules which were.
No censorship.
You could say what you like but you
had to put your name on it at home.
What you wrote arguing that.
That village was so small
that you know people would get immediate
feedback they sound outrageous from the
people they'd offended. We could afford
and since it had no capital we didn't we
weren't obligated by the defamation laws
or anything like that. You
know no one was at risk.
All the individuals be at risk
but certainly not the
publication of assets of zero
and the name in news was the most fascinating
publication i had seen at the time i
had been the editor of student publications
we get the strangest you know mad
reynolds and sort of birth notices
that people calling their
self mango sunshine.
Mango sunshine and things like this with
the most delightful news. But appearing.
And always incredibly immediate
and this used to come out weekly
and i was enormously bonding thing so the
homos association had in effect had its
own news organ
that got out to all the people building
about what was happening with the
negotiations which started with the council
not my own feeling was as soon as we
had established a negotiation
with the council.
We were certainly going to win right.
So soon as we'd certainly negotiate and
home builders put out to everyone.
Start building.
You know we would like crazy because
everything built will be approved.
When the new zoning comes in at
least that will mean that much.
So this this rapidly led to confrontation.
When the council became which was by this
time a little more city council became
aware of how extensive the illegal building
was was it was happening in the hills
they wanted to put the brakes on
and get pull out the bulldozers.
Well at this time. Things
began to move very quickly.
It was felt like a golden period this.
In to be like nothing we could do that
wasn't magical we had balls we had so close.
We had concerts slim dusty came to town.
Walking the main street of dreams and.
I think you know your
slim dusty. Yeah here.
The media you know we're playing at casino.
You know in the air same time with me.
Dropper. We we had a letter
just before the festival.
We were invited to play at the festival
there was a lovely letter from maybe you
know vital part of my partner. Sure.
Noah sure do want to come to dinner come
and meet violet who would like that
and you know slim seen
that enjoyment just lovely people travelling
country towns of our lives just love
this so they came up with their
band and had dinner with us
and we say we want to you know
you've got a night off tomorrow
and i wanted to come to a
concert in the name and hope
that played in the name on whole one time
around with the folk like this guest of
the folk club. So it's a 24 hours to
organize this concert featuring slim dusty
and the best of the first love
and it was a most amazing concert like
the fact everyone's in fact like we will
form. We're just shining that night
and all the townspeople turned out
to see their star slim dusty and.
Slim dusty performed it
was just get a magic.
Those nights and we had naming ceremonies
and healing first to
all this kind of stuff
and for me the the principle of community
organization which i was doing
and sharing with lots of other people
was creating events where people could
experience the joy of community
that what they believed in was affirmed
in the experience of joy together
scheduling. So a night at the folk
club. I remember crying at the songs.
There were some.
It was both the quality of the music in
the voice but also in the sentiments
that people were seeing to each other.
We grew very quickly very tight
as a community and established.
Like i say the norms for the
community the expectation is
that the extraordinary
things happened in yemen
and there are lots of debates about
between vegetarians and movies
and all these kind of stuff
but as if the dreams
that have been seeded by the aquarius
festival began to take form.
In community
and there were sufficient concentration
of people to carry these values into
everyday life and make them realities.
So that for example referring back
to the birth of their own group.
It would only matter of time before
people started having babies families
developing there
and the healings centre was called upon
to help with the birth things. And carol.
Carol's more psychics and you know a
medical medically trained people person.
But see entered into this in the healing
training for acupuncture in good faith.
And goodwill and with lots
of support from people.
Built up this person beyond movement
and birth became a
spiritual experience such
that people preferred to have home births
than go to the lismore base hospital in
the labour ward. Now there outcries of
course from the doctors and calls of fear
and all this kind of stuff
but the end result was
that the labour ward in
lismore changed right.
They made their birthing process is much
more humane much more people centred in a
baby centered.
Than had previously been
and the principles of spiritual midwifery
which been introduced through the new
settlers in then became integrated
in hospital practice in lismore.
So it's like there needs to be a concentration
of people who are willing to have a
home that's wanted this service
and once it was established
and influenced lots of other people as
well. And in. Attitudes towards treece.
The area were settled
by white people first.
North first was people came to this area
to cut down trees the sea to get us into
the primeval forest and first took the cedar
and then it was divided for selection.
The blocks the land was sold down south
and one the conditions was the people
come up here and clear their land.
To create farms. So very
quickly an extensive.
Rainforest
that went from the coast to 40 kilometres
inland its normal size including the
tweed valley right down to the
richmond was almost wiped out
and set up for dairy farms.
The new settlers coming to the area had a
completely different attitude to trees
they've been influenced by the
ecology movement things like that.
So even
when we're preparing for the first we
were proposed by people from the borders
ranges saying are you aware what's
happening at the ranges the border ranges.
While the remnants of the big scrub.
And 974 people are aware of the logging
practices were happening on the night cap
range just behind nimbin where the loggers
were just leaving it so the curtain of
trees by the road and almost
clear felling the property.
But the hillsides under supervision of
the forestry commission which was at the
time calling it selective logging which was
take anything of value dropped the lot
when we were first approached about this
with a sense of frustration what can we do
we're organising a festival
and we don't have the wherewithal to
organize a protest at the same time.
But by 1976 like there was a community
concern about what was happening with the
logging and.
And it erupted at the battle of
training creek and the situation was
that the new settlers had
moved into the area.
When the creaks when the
cricket runs into the china.
And it's like two valleys
across from going.
East and going west start going east
from nimbin it's like two valleys across
and it only went one road up the creek
and at the end of the creek was a 50
hectare forest which was enclosed by rock
walls on the other side so
that part of the reason
that it had such old trees in it was that.
Previous technology was in inaccessible
and the brush box wasn't valued for
that much but now the first
commissioner decided
that boris had to go to look
at a log for its brush box
and the residents complained
about the destruction the forest
and they also pointed out that they didn't
want these logging trucks on the road.
There's only one road
and they were in it in negotiations
of the forest commission
and they came to the silt the first commission
said. The first of their following.
We hear concerns but we don't care
and replied the lismore city council was
to put up signs aimed at the residents.
Beware of logging trucks not no signs aimed
at the low interrupts they take care.
But they care for you've chosen
to live here and you'll suffer.
You don't take notice
of a log or interrupt.
So it was like a slap in the face and
all the negotiations came to nothing.
So the people who were negotiating
that decided protest was called for
and they approached me and
other people for assistance.
Transforming a committee
meeting into a public protest.
Now i i joined the protest
at that stage and i.
I didn't ever want to become involved in
any more committees i have been committed
up to my years along.
I was moving
and i i went along for the role i want to
play with like shaman i wanted to just
work on the energy.
That help would hold a group of people
together who certainly first of all draw a
crowd and we created a bit of
theatre which was performed at the.
The china market using big images and
music to tell the story of the protest
and to announce the people there would
be a meeting at the first following
wednesday and.
The bit of theatre was very
graphic begin each is.
Dancing around and kind of mystical.
Big crowds
and so a dollar man was kind of stuff
so sign ominous signs moving in
and the following wednesday
we had a meeting at the site
and the leaders of the festival.
How do you turn this into a unified group
of people are going to work together and.
Kids the impulse of committee people
is to stand up from the crowd
and talk at them you know.
And i'm saying well there's
other ways to do it
and one of the things they do is to
complete the circle get people to see in a
circle because if we can
get a circle happening.
We've got the ground where
real communication can happen.
And so with a bit of music and assistance
from friends we completed the circle
and it went from being a disparate people
not knowing whether they should be there
or whether they were present to a group
of people sitting down planning a protest
and trusting each other has
everything the basic trust.
So it was that circles tribal circles
became sort of a fundamental ingredient to.
The forest protests that
happened on wednesday
and the following monday.
It was a council meeting in lismore where
the body farmers very farmers one of the
early communities that had announced
that it was going to build regardless
you know which it was doing the morally
correct thing.
It was providing low cost accommodation
to house people so they can raise their
family and no law in the land
should prevent people from doing
that so they took it
totally moral stand and.
Let the council know what they were doing
they were working with the home builders
association
and they were determined to be the pivot
you know the case test case they'd
incorporated themselves as a church
and ready to fight as an ethical community
doing what was right in the times
and the council considered
their case that night
and these national party councils got up
and said things like breaking the law.
I advocate that we knock down
the houses as soon as possible
and in the gallery of the body farmers
with their babies line out you know it was
like a classic you know in this like peasant
class this is the new poor you know
totally ethical and clearly clear
about what they want to do.
Against this where these rantings of these
ageing community leaders who had no
regard no compassion
whatsoever for the people.
So for me it was obvious that
the battle for the forest
and the battle for the houses were one
of the same if we lost the trees we'd
certainly lose the houses because i just
bulldoze houses in the same way they
bulldoze the trees. So the name
in news. Put that message out.
You know to everyone. This was it. This
was crunch time and on the wednesday.
After
that meeting the bulldozers arrived at
the forest they came down by back road.
The telephone tree worked and
we you know within an hour.
We had about 100 people gathered
at the forest and the images
that would have been used in the play were
brought to bear and took great pride in.
Putting the dollar man image on top of
the bulldozer and it became the icon
that sydney morning herald used to and
that sort of daily report of this protest
and we stopped the bulldoze it was only
a matter of time you know more police
and more reinforcements were coming
and it was a big showdown
the minister for forests.
Was totally against the
hippies he was for.
Griffiths any roadies local newspaper
there is going to do a scene.
We printed that article you know more
or less saying they just
rabble rousing hippies
and we're not entirely noticed other we
printed that report in the name a news.
What would happen instead further.
Raise the ire of the people
and created this community.
Now we brought all our
cultural resources to bear on
that protest the musicians
from the folk love came
and wrote anthems first to sing.
The healers were there to help people all
the communication skills we developed in
the home builders association
replied the coming to agreement
and the community was strong
and i remember the day
that the police reinforcements arrived
and they had people from as far as
newcastle rusted on duty to do the show
and they came along they were psyched up
the police were aggressive they really got
to roll us you know and we were we had
a circle at the camp that morning
and.
We had been lots of discussions
that basically we had been unable
to agree what we were going to do.
There was lots of tension lots of fear
in the circle and no clear direction
and we stood together holding in a circle
holding class arms into intertwined
and i'm took off.
And it's always so supply i'm so strong
you feel the spirit lifting us up.
That i know mine. My knees buckled.
I just couldn't stand tears
streaming down my stream.
But one thing was obvious
that we were in the spirit
that some strong in the
spirit we would be together
and we would defend the forest and
we would win it was clear and.
So we yielded before the police. Back.
They they just barged through
they pushed through our lines.
They pushed away the obstacles
and the bulldozers.
Plowed with the forest bearing a road to
take the logs out. But we stayed there.
And then it became obvious
that our perseverance was going to win
the battle the longer we stay there was
costing the police. Heaps.
In the state government they were paying
the police overtime there putting them up
and motels was going to stuff whereas we
were living in a home country this was the
battle of them being through right.
They were the invading
force we owned the hills
and so people would bring us
supplies there bring us food.
We had a camp kitchen co-operative cooking
stuff was the aquarius festival over
again. Right. We were singing and enjoying
ourselves and dancing and talking
and sitting around campfires
we were very good at this.
So for four weeks we maintain
this presence in the forest
and pressure on the logging operations
and as time went by we became stronger
and stronger as time went
by the police became weaker
and weaker as a defence force for the
loggers because every day they talk to
hippies most battles are
sitting around doing nothing.
So the police are sitting in the forest
saying this is a really nice forest isn't
it. And they be so well massaged and.
And so in the end it was like the police
wouldn't allow the logging trucks to go
out without.
Armed guards right without
a convoy of police cars
and policemen which took a
long time to organise so
that the logging operation was
incredibly slow down as well and.
So it was that.
A moratorium was called neville wran
changed his position and talking about.
What he calls it.
You know he rap ag's removed from can
describe me as i said he rapped concern
conservationists within two weeks right
is suddenly realize there were votes.
In conservation and called
a halt to the operation
and an inquiry which.
We knew in the forests we knew we'd won
and it took two years for the
state government to acknowledge
that they weren't going to log a forest
there again it was going to become a state
park. So we won.
And because of the heat that
was generated by that battle
when it came to the housing issue.
The state government stepped in when we
are able to say look we won the forest
and now they're going to get us and
like that the houses pull landers at
that time the minister the late paul land
that was minister for planning stepped in
and employed coal james the planner of
the equus festival to come up with a
solution to the zoning problem which led
to multiple occupancy dwellings up here.
So it was as if we went from a very
short time post the queries festival
when the community was weak
in disparate with a vision
and committed work from a number of
people to create a sense of community
and shared values into a community
that was strong enough to
take on the first commission
and completely reverse attitudes
to logging in the area.
The battle of trainee creek was the
first successful rainforest defence in
australia. The people who fought
that fight went down to the franklin
and taught people not non-violent action.
So they were a major influence in the way
that the franklin was fought the the people
also the nightcap range which is the
one overlooking member a
couple of years later
that anniversary last this year
was defended and the night
that range which was the last major
pocket of rainforest of the big scrub was
turned into a national park.
So within a short time from i
would say from 74 through to 78.
A sense of community had been created that
was strong enough to defend the values.
So they're community and make them real
and it had went from strength to
strength and you know i i think it.
You know get a number of
influences on the north coast
and trace them to aquarian values values
that we had some expression in the name
and festival of 73 taking taking
shape as community practice
and then influencing the wider community.
One
that influences interest me in particular is
attitude towards social change nonviolent
social action
and what i was talking about before about
learning to have meetings together
learning to have affective meetings.
Has now become taken the first
to developed into despair
and empowerment workshops. People
learning skills to develop.
Ways of handling resisting
the nuclear holocaust.
You know melting down the plowshares
how to do this on a world scale.
Into this area came to the
idea of expressing despair
when one of the ways to express
despair and out of the spare doing
that collectively would come agreements
and people being able to work together to
make a difference in their lives in their
communities when that those ideas
combined with rainforest action ideas.
We've got become sort of all
beings which john seed.
And joanna macy wrote a book called thinking
like a mountain which is a kind of a
ritual where people can express.